while we've had a pretty good discipline
around hard disks and scrubbing them and
this is a well understood problem in in
the industry there's still a little bit
of a you know a problem around the way
in which we use solid-state memories and
you know the best security approaches
towards those so you can completely
delete all your contents and eventually
the microcontroller will erase all the
blocks but it's not happening under the
operator control it's not happening
because the user says that it's
happening at the whim of the my
controller today I thought we'd talk
about information in prevalence storage
try to understand some of the
differences interesting some of the
security issues that are different
between them let's look at magnetic
discs so magnetic discs it is literally
like a a record if anyone can remember
records are vinyl records just remember
those and it has a little head little
magnetic reading head that moves in a
night of the magnetic disk and there are
concentric circles here that hold the
data the physical movement of these
drive heads adds latency and so you
often find associated with magnetic
drives comments like the seek time is 10
milliseconds C times having 10
milliseconds for a long time going back
to the 60s and 70s magnetic seek times
were 10 milliseconds and 10 milliseconds
in those days was blooming fast compared
to the processing but these days of
course it's a vast amount of time and 10
milliseconds your processor executes
billions of instructions sometimes
though there may be a flaw from the
magnetic media it may be manufactured
that way or one of the classics being
that if you shake a magnetic drive when
it's working these little heads that sit
very close to the surface actually will
ding the surface and knock some of the
oxide off and you get a fault and that
means that that whatever block that is
in is now failed some systems the
operating system is told about this and
handles it by never using that block and
another the drive hides the fact by
magically if someone accesses this
sector it says oh no you don't want that
block I know I've actually remapped that
to another sector somewhere else
and that bad block in direction or
redirection is very common but of course
if we if all the blocks have previously
been contiguous we've now got a chunk
here and then one block somewhere else
so you notice this in the performance so
one of the arguments as to why to tell
the operating system is it might want to
move the whole file so that it can get a
nice contiguous set of good blocks for
performance reasons so now we move on to
flash memory or solid state drives names
are used interchangeably here we're
using semiconductor memory and the
semiconductor memory while it has one
property that's very similar to disks
which is it's best addressed as blocks
rather than as individual bytes we can
access any block in these memories at
the same speed if there's no difference
between what the last block we read and
the next block would be real it can be
anywhere but these memories have one
particular property that is slightly
irritating in order to write a block we
must first erase it and there's an array
stage whereas with a magnetic drive you
can write a new block of over one that
was already there in one go it takes the
same amount of time as it does to read
in the case of flash memories we must
erase a block before we can write it so
we have to come out with a slightly
different means to actually assign these
blocks there's one other thing that
magnetic media as long as it gets
refreshed every soft and there actually
is able to remember for a long time
flash memory
where's it-- it actually does we're
right over time of magnetic drives will
wear out over time because being
mechanical they will just fail but in
flash memory inside the flash memory
there's a little microcontroller what it
does is a thing called wear leveling it
sets its mission to make sure that each
of the blocks is used with the same
frequency and it does this by
dynamically remapping the blocks so I
may ask for block seventy two and it
goes yeah whatever I will remap that
internally it maintains a table
internally that remaps all these blocks
so let's let's just look at a simple
example let's have our nice simple file
it's composed of contiguous blocks and
then I update one of the blocks so I
want to update block number five and the
microcontroller
down here as well at all so in order to
reuse this I would need to erase it
first and that takes a long time so
rather it looks at somewhere else on the
flash memory and says I'll make out
number five it nomarks that block and
says when you get a run into it arrays
that block so now the process of writing
a block for a file is decoupled from the
erasing of the old contents that's great
so it provides we're leveling it can
make sure that all of the blocks are
used equally hence the lifetime of this
device will be the lifetime of when all
the cells start to fail rather than
there being one particular cell that
happened to get used a lot because it
was a block that got rewritten a lot
there are a number of consequences of
this magnetic drive if you actually look
at hi this little magnetic read head
works what it reads is a constantly
varying magnetic field strength and we
translate that into a series of ones and
zeros by threshold in the signal we say
well lift above this strength it's one
little blue that it's a zero this very
complex signal is not just dependent on
the bit pattern that was last written to
the drive but it actually depends on
what was there previously if we had
previously a zero and then we write a
zero we may have a field strength that's
down here if it was one and then we
write a zero it may be here so still
below our threshold so we still read it
as a zero if it was a 0 and then a 1 it
might be here and if it was a 1 and a 1
might be here now if we built a
different circuit instead of just
discriminating 0 and 1 and we say we
want to find out what was there
previously we could set multiple
threshold levels and we could read what
was there previously before we'd
overwritten it with the new block and
there's actually been used by people to
recover information from the hard drives
and it's one of the reasons why whenever
you dispose of a hard drive you are
advised to run one of the many
algorithms
to rewrite the blocks multiple times
over and over again with very defined
patterns in order to essentially leave
random noise behind rather than trace of
your actual signal and the whole
industry in terms of people securely
erasing magnetic dries and then if
you're paranoid you then physically
destroy it as well but first of all
you've got to destroy the contents now I
who uses these sorts of techniques well
you'd have to say some of your national
security agencies might use these sorts
of techniques to find things if there
are big secrets but people have also
used this just for commercial criminal
activity as well to find out information
well we have a solution to this which is
algorithms that where we rewrite the
blocks over and over again
it erases all trace of the data but oh
dear our flash drives let's remember
what they do
here's the file I want to erase so I run
this algorithm and it says write write
all over these disk blocks but the
microcontroller is going to go oh no
that's going to take too long I'll write
a whole new set of disk blocks and it
puts these on the please arrays these
sometime in the future list as you run
the algorithm multiple times it will
continue to rewrite this file in a new
area of memory leaving behind the actual
data was there previously now the little
microcontroller down here is eventually
going to get around to cleaning these
cells ID and erasing them but until it
does that that did has not gone away
you're quite happily delete all your
files you run this algorithm to rewrite
all the file contents and erase them and
luayn polled all the contents are still
there and this has been used quite a
number of times a classic example of
camera thieves who had erased the flash
memory but hadn't quite sufficiently
erased it to the point of which the
police were able to recover the files
over there previously but it does mean
that that little USB drive or SSD drive
has to be continued to be plugged in so
if you delete all your files and unplug
it then most of the contents has not
actually been erased and it's still
available for someone to rediscover
you buy yourself a 4 gigabyte flash
probably got a 6 gigabyte flash memory
the most amazing thing you then discover
we just threw me for a while because I'd
rather forgotten it works like this